alex every year the smith center hosts
the biggest broadway shows downtown
but with the theater industry and the
touring companies dark there's no sign
the smith center is going to open
anytime
soon today it's asking the city of las
vegas for a little financial help to
stay afloat
the council is expected to approve the
transfer of up to 1.8 million dollars to
the smith center
and it is money that comes from excess
car rental fees and that money is
already earmarked for the theater
the smith centers furloughed two-thirds
of its staff that happened back in march
ceo myron martin says that the smith
center will bring back shows as soon as
possible
but only when it's safe this is a case
of patience
right we just need to have a little bit
of patience to get through this thing
so that we can open successfully and if
we're patient
the tours are going to come back um the
broadway shows are going to come back
the concerts are going to come back
and they're all going to want to come to
the smith center because it's their
favorite place to play
martin says unlike shows on the las
vegas strip the smith center depends on
national
theaters and touring shows and they're
just really not working right now
and the smith center cannot operate at
less than normal capacity which is why
they're still closed